juanita perez is asking for help to
locate her two-year-old son dylan
he was taken from a market in the
mexican state of chiapas
on june 30. juanita says despite the
media attention and help from activists
it took a long time for police and
authorities to begin investigating the
boy's disappearance
i know it's not only my son that
everyone should be looking for but i
know that if we search for him we will
find many other children
that's what i would like for people to
keep looking and keep coming together
not only for my son but for the many
other lost children
juanita's case is far from unique every
day an
average of seven children go missing in
mexico and that rate of daily child
abductions
has almost doubled in the last two years
we believe the disappearance of young
children is linked to illegal adoptions
nationally and internationally and in
the case of adolescent girls the
evidence suggests
they become victims of sex trafficking
and in the case of adolescent voice
we know they are often forced to work
for criminal groups
according to the latest national
statistics more than 73 thousand people
are listed as missing across mexico and
just as forced
disappearances have seen an exponential
growth in recent years
so have protests calling for
accountability
demonstrations like these have become
very common here in the mexican capital
and they're often organized by the
family members of missing persons
and what we hear consistently from
people at this type of protest
is that the government isn't doing
enough to find their missing loved ones
mexico has some of the toughest laws in
the region against human trafficking
but legal experts say a culture of
corruption and impunity
means few cases are ever solved many are
never even investigated
in the absence of state help dozens if
not hundreds of collectives
have been formed by the families of the
disappeared they're on a constant search
for the tens of thousands of missing
persons across the country
an estimated 20 percent of whom are
children and adolescents
20 of disappearances is a very high
percentage
and if you include young adults up to
the age of 25 what the data suggests
is that it's mexico's youth that is
disappearing
[Music]
many compare the phenomenon of forced
disappearances in mexico to an epidemic
that has only worsened over time since
the turn of the century
it's estimated that some 12 thousand
children have gone missing in mexico
most of them between the ages of 13 and
17.
manuel rapalo al jazeera mexico city